and
speaking of ballots
we got a new very interesting poll from
the state of new hampshire this week
according to this new new hampshire poll
for the republican 2024 presidential
primary in the
ever important state of new hampshire
just because it's an early state
ron desantis the authoritarian governor
here in my state of florida
is now ahead
of donald trump
but he's not just ahead
that's not all that's happened here he
hasn't just taken a lead
he has closed a 25 point gap between
trump and desantis
desantis closed the 25 point gap between
the two that existed all the way back in
october of 2021.
back then trump had 4 uh 43 of the vote
desantis had 18 percent
today
desantis has 39 percent
and trump is 37.
still within the margin of error so you
know
trump doesn't need to sound the alarm
bells just yet
but this is an early primary state
if desantis
enters this race
and outperforms trump
in these early states
trump's done
now
i have said many times on my own
programs desantis is far more dangerous
than donald trump
right he has all the same horrific
policies but none of the baggage
that makes him far more dangerous
he can endear himself
himself excuse me
to the more moderate republicans out
there the people who may look at trump
and say no i'm not going to do that
again
they can look at desantis and say oh but
i'll do that
so let me explain the dangers here
over the last year and a half
everybody here on the left we've been
talking about all these horrific laws
that have been passed state by state by
state you know a ban on
books and critical race theory
up here an abortion ban over here
a transgender athlete ban there
transgender affirming care banned over
there
all of those things
have happened here in florida and then
some
you know you've got other states that
have done one or two of these things
florida's the only one that's done all
of them all of them
not to mention the voter suppression not
to mention the piece of legislation that
allows you as a motorist to run down a
protester if they're standing in the
street and they're in your way and not
face any criminal charges
florida pioneered all this folks
we have all of the horrible pieces of
legislation
crammed into one state on top of that
our economy is in the absolute toilet
right now
one of the most unaffordable states to
live in now our housing prices have
risen faster than any other state in
this country under ron desantis and he
has done all of this
tanked our economy and of course passed
all this massively oppressive
legislation
in three years
in fact almost all of it was actually
passed within the last 18 months
he did all of this damage rose to
national prominence
in 18
months folks
just imagine what he could do with four
years in the white house
now personally
i don't know that desantis would do well
on a republican debate stage
the guy gets very flustered very easily
he loses his temper he gets you know
kind of flustered the way marco rubio
did back in the 2015 debates which was
hilarious to watch
so i don't know that desantis could
actually survive that but if he did
he may be a shoe-in
and he would be very difficult for any
democrat to beat definitely difficult
for any republican to beat
because as as horrible as this
legislation is as bad as some of the
things he said are
he doesn't have any real
scandals you know there's no real
skeletons in the closet he's just a bad
guy
and unfortunately a lot of this
legislation that we look at as just
absolutely repulsive and oppressive
most people do support a lot of it not
all of it but a lot of it
that's the worst part
it's not turning off enough people
so desantis finally pulling ahead of
trump in the state of new hampshire
that's bad
it's not bad for you know trump really
it's bad for the united states
we have to take another break again i am
fair and cousins find me on youtube
youtube.com slash the ring of fire and
youtube.com fair and balanced and i also
host the weekly ring of fire podcast you
can check that out for free or you can
become a member if you'd like at
rofpodcast.com again i'm farin cousins
in for david pakman and we'll be right
back
i never have time to read all of the
nonfiction books that i want to read our
sponsor blinkist has solved the problem
for me in a way because blinkist takes
thousands of the best and newest
non-fiction books extracts the key
takeaways and then you can either read
or listen to them in 15 minutes i read
all the time i love narrative nonfiction
i read economics i read all these
different things as i said before i
would love to have time to read more
history i just don't right now
especially with a newborn you should see
what's going on in the middle of the
night but
uh with blinkist i was able to read in
fact i listened to a 15-minute audio
version of putin's people by katherine
belton with what's going on in ukraine
and russia i just wanted more history
how did
uh in fact the book is called how the
kgb
took back russia and then took on the
west i wanted to learn how did this
adversarial situation develop
what is the history of the putin kgb
coming to power etc i did not have time
to read that book in full but in just 15
minutes with blinkist i was able to get
all of the uh key points which now i can
use when i am talking about ukraine and
russia and have more context blinkist
has condensed over 5000 non-fiction
books in 27 categories try blinkist free
for seven days and get 25 off a
subscription at blinkist.com pacman the
link is down below